[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du sky échos le magazine
qui vous racontent la vie des acteurs
économiques de saint quentin en yvelines
nous sommes au coeur du quartier
économique de l'agglomération
la venue du centre à montigny le
bretonneux devant le chantier du futur
bâtiment native une construction piloté
par le promoteur immobilier codic avec
orange comme utilisateur des locaux dans
ce numéro nous reviendrons sur l'avancée
du chantier et sur les futurs projets de
codic à saint quentin en yvelines c'est
ce que je vous propose de découvrir dans
ce 23ème numéro sky est qu un challenge
d'open innovation a été lancée le 6
septembre dernier une initiative des
grands groupes de la software république
avec renault en tête objectif proposer
des projets de mobilité durable est
connecté
le chantier du bâtiment n'at-il devrait
se terminer en mars 2022 le promoteur
immobilier codic réfléchit déjà à
l'après avec le réaménagement du
quartier de la gare enfin découverte du
futur magasin les siphonner du bocal
céline roblin lance son activité
entrepreneuriale avec cette boutique
spécialisée dans le vrac on commence
cette émission avec le 4.0 mobility
challenge une initiative lancée par la
software république plusieurs membres au
sein de cette software république le
groupe renault atos dassault systèmes
stmicroelectronics thales ou encore
orange les inscriptions à ce challenge
open innovation ont commencé le 6
septembre et dureront jusqu'au 13
octobre 2021 pme start up entrepreneurs
et instituts de recherche peuvent y
participer
objectif proposer des projets au service
d'une mobilité durable et intelligente
pour plus d'informations vous pouvez
vous rendre sur le site internet qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran
[Musique]
le chantier a débuté en juin 2010 9 le
bâtiment native a été conçu par le
promoteur immobilier codic avec comme
locataire le groupe orange une
infrastructure de dix neuf mille mètres
carrés avec huit étages pour en parler
nous sommes avec yann le gall le
directeur général adjoint de codic
france bonjour bonjour nicolas
alors où en est on dans ce chantier
écoutez on est dans le run final à
savoir que nous devons livrer cette
opération dans six mois à orange donc le
principal locataire de l'opération et
hsbc qui l'a acheté pour le compte de ça
et ces pays elise et pierre alors
quelles sont les caractéristiques de ce
bâtiment coûté ses derniers nés de codic
france donc c'est une opération je
dirais abdou day they qui intègre tous
les besoins essentiels des utilisateurs
et d'ailleurs elle a été plébiscitée par
un grand utilisateur de la région ile de
france qui est le groupe orange vous
l'avez dit l'idée c'est de pouvoir
permettre à orange d'adapter ses modes
de travail et de pouvoir travailler
notamment tout ce qui est en mode projet
et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui on parle
beaucoup de l'obsolescence du parc
tertiaire alors avant on en parlait
plutôt sous l'angle de la performance
énergétique et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
l'enjeu qui nous anime c'est pouvoir
permettre les nouveaux usages et pour ce
faire on adapte la technique de nos
bâtiments et notamment par exemple tout
ce qui est le renouvellement d'air les
peluches suppose c'est dans l'air du
temps à l'aspect environnemental aussi
prises en compte bien sûr alors ça c'est
quelque chose qu'on prend en compte sur
des opérations durent depuis de
nombreuses années cet immeuble est bien
évidemment multi labellisé avec bill est
évidemment le label hqe young est un
label français géré par certivéa on a
également le label breeam ou anton vise
l'excellence sur ce label qui est un
label international
et puis également un nouveau label qui
s'appelle own score qui permet de
certifier la connectivité du bâtiment
donc là on en sort du spectre
environnementale mais c'est quelque
chose qui est très important aujourd'hui
on le voit notamment avec l'avènement du
télétravail il faut que les gens
puissent travailler à distance et pour
ce faire il faut que les immeubles eux
aussi soit connecté vous l'avez dit
livraison mars 2022 mais le travail de
codic sur le territoire de saint quentin
en yvelines n'est pas fini alors il est
pas finie et puis surtout c'est une
histoire qui dure depuis maintenant des
années 2000 puisqu'on a déjà des réalisé
plus de cent mille mètres carrés de
bureaux sur le territoire l'avenir de
codic sur le territoire ces deux
opérations une qui est juste à côté donc
deux natives qui est vraiment une autre
une opération hypercentre posé sur la
gare rer de saint quentin en lieu et
place d'un immeuble emblématique qui
s'appelle l' anneau rouge voilà qui est
un immeuble totalement vétustes conçu
dans les années 70 et aujourd'hui encore
une fois en partenariat avec les
pouvoirs publics on travaille sur une
opération qui fera à terme 25
millimètres carrés l'idée c'est de
redonner depuis le parc des sources de
la bièvre une perspective sur la gare de
saint-quentin est amené deux immeubles
de part et d'autre avec les nouvelles
caractéristiques du bureau qu'on évoque
et sur lesquels on n'arrête pas de on
n'arrête pas de didier nos d'innover
donc c'est le prochain défi de codic
réaménager l'espace vraiment proche de
la gare voilà alors on a on a deux
projets effectivement celui-ci
extrêmement centrale et puis on a
travaillé il ya quelques années sur le
sur le pas du lac donc à quelques
encablures d'ici donc dans un
environnement un peu plus vert et là on
travaille avec un autre architecte qui
s'appelle ateliers de 3,4 sur un projet
de campus urbain dans lequel on va
développer un concept de bio philly
extrêmement importante parce que
aujourd'hui l'enjeu des entreprises de
demain c'est de faire revenir leurs
salariés au bureau leur donner un cadre
de vie agréable et surtout de perdre de
pouvoir permettre les échanges puisque
c'est ça qui fait avancer aujourd'hui
nos sociétés ce sont des nouveaux sujets
à suivre sur tv 78 les futurs projets de
codic merci yann le gall pour ces
précisions merci de nous avoir dit je
rappelle que vous êtes le directeur
général adjoint de codic français puis
on va tout de suite rejoindre le
locataire le groupe orange pour nous
expliquer comment il va utiliser ce
nouvel espace
[Musique]
eh bien nous avons rejoint jacques
travail à le directeur adjoint des
projets immobiliers pour le groupe
orange bonjour bonjour nicolas
alors vous allez être l'utilisateur de
ces espaces sept étages c'est ça sept
étages sur huit est donc comment voulez
ça allait l'utiliser combien de
personnes vont venir ici et sur quelle
activité alors 1200 calories bon orateur
orange vont nous rejoindre pour
enjoindre l'immeuble en d'ici juin à
septembre 2022 1200 collaborateurs qui
sont principalement des chercheurs des
techniciens réseaux est également une
équipe commerciale alors on le sait
orange c'est l'opérateur téléphonique
vous déployez aussi la fibre la
connexion de demain la 5g aussi sur quoi
vont travailler sur quels sujets vont
travailler ses collaborateurs les
collaborateurs de native donc localisés
sur saint quentin en yvelines vont
travailler sur la région sur le pôle
régional en lien avec les directions
centrales de guides de france
pour moi je dirais développer le réseau
orange et le service au client par
exemple qu'est ce qu'on pourrait
imaginer ici sur ce plateau alors vous
avez imaginé à la fois des espaces de
convivialité des espaces de réunion des
espaces collaboratifs des espaces de
concentration sur l'ensemble des
plateaux évidemment le l'espace du
huitième étage avec sa terrasse va
abriter une cafétéria également
incorpore king pour également abriter
les itinérants sur sur le secteur et
profitez en fait j'irai du plus bel
espace avec cette vue qui est
extraordinaire merci jacques travailla
pour ces précisions merci à vous nicolas
je rappelle que vous êtes directeur
adjoint des projets immobiliers pour le
groupe orange et puis bien aux
rendez-vous dans un an fait exactement
au plaisir elle ouvrira sa boutique dans
les prochaines semaines céline roblin se
lancent dans l'entrepreunariat avec sa
boutique baptisée les siphonner du bocal
située à voisins le bretonneux elle sera
spécialisée dans la vente de produits
alimentaires et non alimentaires en vrac
découverte de son histoire dans ma vie
d'entrepreneur
[Musique]
si céline roblin 46 ans j'habite à
montigny-le-bretonneux et donc j'ai
décidé d'ouvrir siphonner du bocal qui
sera une épicerie brac zéro déchet donc
début octobre 2021 ici et voisins le
bretonneux
[Musique]
la plupart des produits seront donc sans
emballage donc servir en bocaux en silo
avec vos propres contenants ou bien sûr
je vous en propose ray et il y aura
aussi quelques produits on va
préemballés mais avec l'ocde des
emballages consignes et principalement
et puis des produits français locaux le
plus possible
c'est une reconversion professionnelle
j'ai travaillé 25 ans dans
l'événementiel donc j'ai organisé
principalement des réceptions de mariage
et l'événementiel donc a été touché par
la crise sanitaire du coc vide donc j'ai
réfléchi et ce secteur d'activité ma m'a
plu puisque moi-même voilà j'ai opté
pour une démarche zéro déchet dans ma
vie
pour créer l'entreprise effectivement il
ya une partie de l'apport personnel un
abri un prêt bancaire et j'ai obtenu
donc après un prêt d'honneur via la
région en 50 ans du libre pour le
financement j'avais aussi lancé une
campagne de financement participatif
ça m'a permis de pouvoir acheter batoul
et les silos que vous voyez là au départ
c'était pas forcément prévu puisque
c'est un beau budget en fait ça m'a
permis de le faire
le but pour moi c'est vraiment de deux
d'être assez accessible que ses produits
sont accessibles et de voile à favoriser
l'achat en vrac le plus possible pour
qu'on puisse réduire au maximum ses
déchets
[Musique]
c'est un spécialiste des solutions
digitales dans le secteur de la
construction et du bâtiment batiweb
groupe est une pme de 120 collaborateurs
basés à montigny le bretonneux situé
près de la gare de saint quentin en
yvelines elle recherche actuellement un
responsable acquisitions au sein de la
direction marketing c'est la séquence
ailerons
[Musique]
bâti un groupe c'est une société qui
composait de trois entités batiweb qui
est sa marque médias historiques
existent depuis plus de 20 ans qui
informe les professionnels du bâtiment
et l'eau artisans et marchands online
[Musique]
on est un acteur dit de l'intermédiation
donc de mise en relation entre des
particuliers et des professionnels
[Musique]
e
on recrute un poste de responsable
acquisitions au sein de la direction
marketing
debaty web pour la marque hello artisans
on recherche un expert vraiment un
expert des solutions digitales un expert
de l'acquisition digital on a besoin
absolument de générer des leads rôle de
générer des demandes de devis
[Musique]
la capacité d' analyse compréhension de
l'environnement dans lequel dans lequel
on est une maîtrise du business model
c'est à dire le cpl travailler en équipe
l'équipe marketing ces huit personnes
quatre personnes qui sont dédiés à
l'acquisition mais c'est aussi des
équipes commerciales c'est des équipes
de qualification et de production avec
lesquels il faut partager en permanence
on recherche vraiment quelqu'un
d'expérimenté et qui vient de ceux de ce
milieu là entre 5 à 7 ans d'expérience
quelqu'un qui a déjà évidemment mis en
oeuvre des stratégies des campagnes
d'acquisition au lead ensuite on
recherche quelqu'un qui a une culture du
web une culture de la performance et qui
est orienté revenus la formation de base
est une formation
digital en école de commerce ou en école
dédiée et spécialisée dans le digital en
bac + 4 bac + 2 à bac + 5
c'est la fin de ce numéro merci de
l'avoir suivi émission à revoir en
replay sur notre site internet ou sur
l'application mobile tv 78 à bientôt sur
notre antenne
[Musique]